[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de Francia 24 en
2021 Colombia registró 4.708 El
nacimientos en niñas entre los 10 y los
14 años de edad esto es violencia sexual
la semana andina de la prevención del
embarazo en la infancia y en la
adolescencia en 2022 busca concientizar
sobre la normalización de estas
violaciones a los derechos de las
jóvenes Especialmente cuando se trata de
niñas de 14 años o menos pues este fue
el único grupo de edad en el que
aumentaron las maternidades forzadas con
relación al embarazo en adolescentes de
15 a 19 años se presentó una reducción
del 4% entre el 2020 y el 2021 sin
embargo en 2021 se registró un
incremento en los nacimientos del
segundo o tercer hijo o hija de este
grupo de edad
vamos a conversar sobre esas cifras y
sobre lo que representan en un país
latinoamericano como Colombia para ello
la conversación es con Johana blanco
barreto coordinadora de Educación
integral de la sexualidad en el fondo de
población de las Naciones Unidas la Umpa
Colombia Johana bienvenida a ella soy y
Comencemos por el principio porque el
embarazo temprano constituye un abuso de
poder
Hola Ángela y un saludo para todos y
todas Pues realmente es una hoja de
poder porque un adolescente no embaraza
a un adolescente es decir las relaciones
que se están dando y que producen la el
embarazo en la infancia en la
adolescencia se puede estar dando entre
niñas y adolescentes con hombres que
pueden superar por 40 años la diferencia
de edad básicamente estas son relaciones
inequitativas relaciones de poder que
reflejan pues otras inequidades de otro
tipo como son las inequidades en razón
de la discapacidad en razón de la
ruralidad
etcétera entonces necesitamos
desnaturalizar precisamente estas
prácticas y entender principalmente que
todo acto sexual con menor de 14 años es
un delito y que tener relaciones
sexuales con menor de 18 años Pues
también se considera una un abuso de ese
poder y que deberíamos propender por
relaciones mucho más equitativas en
nuestro país y en nuestra región bueno
Yohana ya que estábamos en ello pues
quisiera ahondar más en ese tema porque
al menos en países como Colombia en
países latinoamericanos se habla mucho
de mamás jóvenes pero es que uno no
puede considerar que una niña de 12 o 13
años que entró en embarazo es una mamá
joven eso es un caso de violencia sexual
eso es un caso de abuso y así está
tipificado de hecho en nuestro Código
Penal entonces ahí qué está pasando
de acuerdo es un abuso sexual de acuerdo
a nuestro Código Penal y
tenemos que avanzar en la
desnaturalización de estas prácticas y
en la identificación de estas prácticas
como un delito y como una vulneración a
los derechos humanos y a los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos lo que estamos
viendo Es que cerca en el 2021 cerca de
5000 embarazos en niñas de 10 a 14 años
pero solo 800 entraron al
restablecimiento de derechos esto por
citas del instituto colombiano de
bienestar familiar Entonces dónde están
las otras 4.200 porque no las
identificamos porque no activamos la
ruta bien sea por salud por las
instituciones educativas o por otro
medio esto nos habla de los grandes
retos que tenemos para desnaturalizar
este tipo de violencias y para
reconocerlas como una vulneración a los
derechos de las niñas precisamente para
allá iba mi siguiente pregunta y era en
Qué deberían consistir estas rutas de
que se deben activar para las niñas y
adolescentes que entran en una situación
de maternidad forzada o que entran en
una situación abuso sexual y Es que
además tengamos en cuenta Yohana que
casi que la mayoría Por poco sería la
mayoría de casos de abuso sexual en
Colombia Pues están en estos grupos
poblacionales
de acuerdo acá tenemos unos grandes
retos a nivel institucional para
fortalecer las capacidades de los
actores de salud de justicia de
protección de Educación que hacen parte
de esta ruta de atención a
sobrevivientes o Víctimas de violencias
sexuales y de violencias de género de
manera general y por supuesto estas
rutas están determinadas de manera
general o a nivel nacional pero tienen
que territorializarse tienen que
adaptarse a las características y
posibilidades de cada territorio Pues lo
mismo tener una ruta de atención en
Bogotá o en Medellín como ciudades
capitales a tenerla en guapi en bosconia
antiguo allí el trabajo debe ser muy
fuerte y muy sostenido en fortalecer
estas rutas y por supuesto en promover
los derechos sexuales y reproductivos
para que las personas conozcan sus
derechos y los exijan bien Y entonces en
este contexto que estamos hablando pues
se celebra esta semana La semana andina
de la prevención del embarazo en
adolescentes Y pues también en niñas y
ustedes a lo que invitan es a hablar
claramente de sexualidad pareciera obvio
y sin embargo la educación sexual sigue
siendo una lucha en países como Colombia
Así es Hablemos claro Esa es la
invitación que él hace los jóvenes
quisieron hacerle a todo el país porque
esta es una iniciativa que nace de las
juventudes específicamente del Magdalena
a partir de un proyecto que tenemos aquí
porque ellos y ellas lo que dicen es
nadie nos habla o no nos habla
claramente no nos habla abiertamente y
allí tenemos unos desafíos en las
instituciones educativas también en las
familias y en la sociedad en general
porque nos han enseñado que la
sexualidad es algo vergonzoso que es
algo de lo que no se habla es algo
incluso pecaminoso o que nos genera
culpa y allí la educación integral en
sexualidad es fundamental para
fortalecer los conocimientos y las
capacidades de los agentes educativos
tanto en la escuela como fuera de ella
que interactúan con niños niñas y
adolescentes por eso estamos
implementando diferentes acciones para
fortalecer a las y los docentes para
fortalecer los mismos procesos
pedagógicos al interior de las
instituciones educativas pero también a
fortalecer otros agentes educativos
fuera del contexto escolar como son los
Nacional de salud actores
educativos de El icbf por ejemplo u
otros actores porque en todos estos
espacios podemos educar en sexualidad
que ves en una educación con un enfoque
de derechos con un enfoque de género con
información científica y precisa Y por
supuesto gradual No le vamos a enseñar
lo mismo a un niño de 6 años que a un
adolescente de 16 debe estar en adecuada
al desarrollo cognitivo físico emocional
y sexual de ellos y demás bueno eso es
una parte y es la responsabilidad que
nos atañe como formadores y a los que se
están formando Pero cómo hacemos para
educar a los que ya son adultos es decir
aquellos que aprendieron desde pequeños
la idea de que la violación Es lo normal
y de que la mujer utilizada objetivizada
Es lo normal Entonces porque es que ahí
es donde viene el gran problema y los
casos no reportados y el subregistro con
violaciones y con niñas que simplemente
no tienen acceso a los sistemas de salud
de manera efectiva y adecuada
Sí allí estamos asumiendo pues todo el
marco normativo que tiene el caso
Colombia tiene un marco normativo muy
robusto y por ejemplo a través de las
escuelas de familias de padres madres y
cuidadores podemos llegar a las familias
para que en su corresponsabilidad en la
formación integral de niños niñas
adolescentes pues puedan hacerlo de
verdad de una manera integral
reconociendo que la sexualidad es parte
de la identidad y reconociendo esta
vulneración de derechos no
desnaturalizando Esto no es un proceso
fácil Esto no se da de la noche a la
mañana pero es posible es posible
transformar estas normas sociales de
género también a través de incidencia de
comunicación para el desarrollo de
incidencia de formación permanente de
acompañamiento y para esto por supuesto
necesitamos la voluntad política de
todas las entidades para que se sumen en
los diferentes espacios a los que llegan
con las comunidades para visibilizar y
transformar estas prácticas Bueno vamos
a lo que sufren las principales víctimas
cuáles son las consecuencias Johana de
forzar maternidades de tener niñas
siendo madres consecuencias para estas
niñas madres y para esas niñas y niños
que llegaron Sin ser pedidos planeados Y
por supuesto sin que sin que sus
progenitores están listas
bueno Hay consecuencias de orden
biológico las niñas y las adolescentes
tienen hasta cuatro veces más de
probabilidad de complicarse en su parto
o su postparto pero también hay
consecuencias a nivel social a nivel
económico a nivel familiar porque muchas
de estas niñas y adolescentes crían a
sus hijos sin su pareja sin la persona
responsable de esta paternidad tienen
que reconfigurar sus sueños sus
proyectos de vida
y también hemos encontrado a través de
un estudio el estudio Milena que tienen
mucha menos probabilidad de acceder a
trabajos bien remunerados entonces
Hay consecuencias de múltiple de orden y
además tienen más probabilidad de volver
a ser madres lo que
fortalece este círculo de pobreza y
también de violencias en el que vivimos
y de desigualdad Johana Muchísimas
gracias a usted por aclararnos un poco
el panorama
Y bueno pues seguimos atentos las cifras
no mienten y no avanza mucho el país en
esta materia gracias a usted por estar
con nosotros y a nuestros televidentes
sigan en Francia 24 y nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]